okay so welcome to the D mice conference
the summer conference we have a couple
at the end of the summer that are kind
of special because we have an internship
program that's funded by the National
Library of Medicine I'm David door the
current p I of the program actually our
chair bill Hirsch wrote the original
grant and ran the program for most of
its existence and we're lucky enough to
get a set of mostly undergraduate
interns who get to learn a little bit
about informatics and related
disciplines and then their most favorite
part at the end of the summer is to
present for the conference so we'll have
three presentation today and I'll
introduce the insurance who are
presenting actually introduce all of
them because their mentors are going to
listen to the live stream or listen to
the YouTube but aren't here right now so
the first one is mark mark is working
with Melissa handle who's an intelligent
mark goes to school at the University of
Southern California where apparently
you're majoring in computer science and
business administration is that right
that's a nice one with a minor
philosophy so the way they set up our
setup is he'll talk for about 15 minutes
or so for about his project that he
worked on little get a little sense of
what it's like to work in that area and
then there'll be about five minutes for
questions as always please press down
the buttons in the front if you're in
the room so that the questions can be
heard and do we have somebody monitoring
the feed so in case there's questions
that come over the feed okay our chair
will okay you should teach the you
should you should teach you should tweet
you should tweet with the hashtag demise
DM i seee clump conf alright great so
I'll let mark go ahead and get started
great
so how do my presentation is visualizing
genetic and so my summer internship was
with the monarch initiative and how many
of you in this room have heard of the
monarch initiative right a good number
so monarch initiative has several has
several goals the main one that I felt
like I was focusing on was like
providing a portal for exploration like
phenotype based similarity and the
monarch initiative basically wants to
help bio researchers better understand
you know the genome and like phenotypes
on the genome and how they relate to
each other especially cross species is
something my supervisor Melissa handle
is a huge fan of so like my how does
they're like phenotypic like diseases
relate to human diseases and zebrafish
are the big ones that the monarch
initiative works on and I'll show you
that later on so phenotypes where are
they on the genome and like what
correlations can we observe is the
question that I was helping answering to
researchers and it's what the monarch
initiative basically does and phenotypes
are basically anything that you know
genetic how your genetics show
themselves like through hair or disease
or mainly focusing on disease so as in
the main example going through so
visualizing genetic it could seem very
simple because we have an actual picture
of genetics but you can't really tell a
lot from there like you can't say oh
right there is the there's the gene that
you know correlates to cancer or two
brown hair like but this is the highest
quality picture we have of DNA that's
pretty cool so for humans we like to say
this is DNA and that's how everything is
sorted out but also that's kind of hard
to like label and say
each part is the part that we're saying
so how can like actual genomic and
phenotypic data be conveyed visually
it's a very hard question and a question
reserved for biologists much better than
I being a computer science major so
luckily the answer was given to me and
so this is from the University of no
it's brick state and so they worked and
add this this is one of many examples
that I was given this is the one I like
the most because there's some nice color
coding going on with the phenotypes the
bands are pretty simple to understand
like each one is a chromosome and I'm a
huge fan of colors so I use this as my
main inspiration for my project moving
forward and yeah so the technology that
I had to use to develop my project was
the main one was d3 which is a
JavaScript library it's a graphical
library which helps you design and code
fancy-looking thing which for visualizer
is very nice and then uh the base that I
built off of was an angular JavaScript
which is also a pretty advanced
JavaScript library jQuery like pretty
basic pretty good github was where I
pulled all the information from was able
to communicate and share my code with
others skype was very helpful because we
the monarch initiative partners with a
lot of different researchers in berkeley
and in san diego but not anymore and in
other places and so skyping and being
able to communicate at any time during
the day was very useful and then a shout
out to my favorite development ideas
like IntelliJ the best one for sure for
JavaScript Ellison and Java so yeah I
will now show you what this was all
about
so it's good for you look at the monarch
initiative so this is the main site and
as you can see the main thing is like
diseases described with phenotypes and
Jean berry ation Association so the main
focus of this is diseases and the
phenotypes that they're related to and
different model organisms and like the
genes that they're spotted on to and and
so as like researchers would go on and
like want to look at different genes or
like you know types and see where they
are there's a fizzling this graph which
is really cool and probably the best
part of this website but if you like go
to a specific gene and wait for it to
load or we just did a new release so
there's there might be some bugs okay
let's try to go to a disease so there's
this disease that doesn't have any data
with it but anyway all of it would just
be what you're accustomed to seen in
them database which is like letters and
numbers and all like really tailored to
like a scientist who knows exactly what
they're doing and there's no real
visualization that's easy to like
compare with other things or see the
cluster of it on the on the genome and
so since I was doing since I was doing
chromosome visualizations age this is
what other models look like like this is
kind of an interactive one and that
would be very hard to dig through and
there's nothing there that would help
you like graphically look and say oh
yeah I totally understand everything
that shown to me there and so it was
kind of hard to find like a base point
to jump off of but luckily there was
this guy Paul Parsons and he had a
pretty good chromastone visualizer based
on angular
and show you that so this is pretty much
the chromosome number one of the human
and as you can see like very graphical
as you hover over it like shows you the
band name and it's kind of easy to
understand and so this was a very good
way we thought me and my supervisors
that this was a good way of representing
the chromosome and since this is all
open source I was able to pull from
github and base all my work off of like
this chromosome band and so my work
would mostly be to take the data that
the monarch initiative is collecting and
collaborating with others of phenotypic
data and to map it on to this chromosome
and so that's what I did and I shall now
show you the results
alright here it is so I'll start off
with where I started so I had this I was
able to take Paul Parsons original code
and just map out any chromosome I wanted
to the data that we were pulling which
is from Joffrey and that's just like a
bunch of all the features on the entire
human genome is in that like database in
the huge Jason I was able to pull that
and it starts with chromosome 22 which
is like for demo purposes that's all I
have displayed here this is just like
it's easier to pull the very first one
from the Jason so this is the band the
features are all the same when you hover
it over it it like gives you the ID of
the band and and that's it and so for
down purposes I needed to pull
independently because at first it was
easier to just drop automatically but
there had to be more like user
interaction especially on the live on
the website you'd need like users to
select which bearings they wander around
what crumbs don't so it had to be
dynamically pulled so that's the purpose
of this like field so let's say we
wanted a hundred the first hundred
barring some films on 22 there they are
displayed and so as you hover over them
it like tells you the type oh that's
right so there's many types of
phenotypes and we didn't decide how we'd
want to group them and it had to be
user-defined so just as a proof of
concept I ordered them by the type of
variant that they are which is
substitution copy number variation
sequence alteration insertions so new
hub and those circles represent every
single type and so the first thing I did
was I map a single one like all general
phenotypes onto the center of the band
and then I made a color scale so on this
one where it's like almost a pink
there's one substitution but then on the
dark scarlet you can see there's 18
substitutions and so I designed a very
simple easy algorithm to make it so that
no color is really too dark or too light
and it's always relative like if we were
to pull 500 it's going to load and this
one still has the most but it has 79 now
this very light one has four but it's
still visible in the relative 279 it's
like so small and so that's where I was
and then we needed to start displaying
different types of area to as you can
see i was able to implement that as well
and so I was able to stack them as
related to my first inspiration of the
color-coded variants based on the
phenotype that they represent being
stacked on top of each other and then I
had to work on being able to remove some
of them based on what the user would
want so i just did simple checkboxes
once again it's like a proof of concept
so it automatically just changes so
there's no more substitutions listed and
then let's say we don't want to see
covered copy number variation we just
want to see assertion so there's only a
few insertions one there there's three
on this band and uh moving on I'd have
to create a window for users if they
wanted to just like one area so if you
click on a bandits looks that entire
band and then you're allowed to go in
and like change the coordinates that you
want if I actually wanted from 107 and
then it goes like a little to the other
band and you can move it around
graphically and so I'd liked you have to
pull the data of all these different
features and that's displayed in this
table down here and this is a lot of
scientific jargon and we would be able
that this was also once again just like
as a proof of concept we could I could
easily make that more user like family
and like describe exactly what the
variant is in like layman's terms and so
it just has the ID the variant label and
looks good when you deselect
substitutions it gets updated in the
table too and so the table only displays
the type that use
so if i only have insertion there's only
one on that in that selection so there's
only one there but there's three on this
man so now there's three on the table
and yeah finally we noticed that there
were some features that span various
bands and bands are kind of a kind of an
arbitrary form of measurement and one of
my supervisors Nicole Washington is a
huge non fan of them and console wanted
me to be moving away from them she
didn't like that I constant was
centering it on the band because she's
like bands mean nothing and
scientifically doesn't matter at all and
so I had to display like when they move
across just so I could prove that I have
that data and so each one the lines
represent like when feature like spans
multiple bands and when you hover over
like tells me there's one standing there
and and if he likes like click on that
it's going to select the entire so that
one feature spans that entire area and
stops about like right before the next
band and so it was kind of kind of cool
and so this was all done with deep three
of course that's why it's so dynamic and
so easy it's a great JavaScript library
and then finally scientists aren't a fan
of horizontal dance I don't know why so
what I was working on for the last few
weeks is just to control it feigning
debted vertical and I was able to do
that where it seamlessly is able to
transition from horizontal to vertical
view and pretty proud of that and it's
much better now because as you saw from
the original example all the bands were
vertical and it's just the way it's been
done it's how people are used to
visually seeing this and so the whole
point of this was just to make it more
interactive because the picture I showed
you before it's just a static
representation of features and variants
on chromosome and this is much more
interactive and if when we're when this
will be implemented on the monarch
initiative website it could be
easily tailored to each person what they
wanted to see on what region and and be
very much easier to sort and so moving
on what I'd have to mainly focus on is
setting that the window would not be a
predefined band but in fact would be
whatever the user would want it to be
like 50,000 DNA base pairs and so then
like each circle will be centered on
like 50,000 and you could see which and
then when you click on there it would
zoom in to that 50,000 base pair and
then it is like more list out the
variance and I designed my code so be
easier to build off of two later
implement these things and yeah that's
pretty much it I think of this and so I
finally like to say thank you to my main
supervisor Melissa handle that Nathan
done was also a great supervisor he was
the main computer scientist I was doing
a bunch of hackathons with on this
technical Washington down and Berkeley
helped a lot with me being able to
understand the biology behind me because
I'm not a biologist and hence chef check
in the back helped me a lot he was
always there most consistently one in
the office matthew brush help Jeremy
Swan and Seth carbon helped a lot with
jhappi and pulling all the varied data
and helping me understand the best way
to do that they made a really good
loader server that was really good
shakeem results in the office to help me
a lot Chris conduit unfortunately has
left the project but he was incredible
with supplying all the variant data that
I was able to display and so yeah and
there's a
I noticed that when you're listening the
features in that box below there were a
lot of them yeah but the rendition was
only showed like one or two items was
there ever a need to zoom in or zoom out
on certain areas because there's a lot
of detail packed in them um I mean there
is a need I would it wasn't that high on
the priority list so I didn't implement
it yet but yeah you're right cuz like
especially when I'm pulling 500 and this
band is so densely populated when I
click on it the table has like so much
and it's so hard to go through and once
again as seen by like if i remove
substitutions and copy number variations
it gets much smaller I can easily like
limit that down to what the user would
want to see and so it wouldn't be a
problem to just quickly change it to
have the person only see the variants
that are related to a certain phenotype
or a disease that he wanted to see and
only display that in a table as a that
all the functionalities here because all
this is like a proof of concept and the
concept is that I can easily alter
what's displayed on the table based on
what the user actually wants to see
yeah so I said earlier there were like
Seth and Juwan date baya they made this
forget that oh yeah it's right the
Golder server manager and pretty much
it's a very nice way of it's made to
work with the goal or data set that
we're pulling and all that it is a huge
Jason it has like 250 500 thousand
different features and has all the
chromosome band data all the variants
every feature that is on the human
genome and so it is so large but because
of the server that they created for
polling data it's much easier it's one
big Jason so there is no perfect way to
be able to go in but the way they did it
is you're allowed to like query special
like special cruise which I could show
you on my computer but in the code when
I set a query right now how I was doing
this I do like stark own star which is
the entire Jason if I do like star and
then I forget the certain ID number
those are it's only going to give me
like bands and no other type of types of
features and so then I could like pull
the bands and draw every chromosome that
I would need without rooting through the
entire thing and so there's this server
that like makes query very easy to get
exactly what I want on where I wanted
and so moving forward like when a user
wouldn't want to be on chromosome 22 and
having all the features displayed I
could just set a different amount of a
different set of queries that he could
then query and have that displayed for
the user
so now we're going to hear from nick
nick is a junior at just finished his
junior year going into a senior year at
Reed College here in Portland he's
majoring in economics and mathematics
and so this I really since informatics
has is very cross-disciplinary and a lot
of our work including my work touches on
sort of how data information and
knowledge flows through the health care
system and how that might influence
health reform and the feedback loop in
there he's actually working with the
Center for Health System effectiveness
with john mcconnell and the graven and
others some of you are in the room now
looking at some some more health
economics type of study so I think this
would be very interesting thank you hold
it up thank you everyone for coming
today and so like dave was beginning to
talk about the a lot of the work that I
have done with chcs this summer's been
kind of looking broadly at health
systems and in particular John my mentor
a lot of work to study the coordinated
care organizations in Oregon and the
track a number of things about them in a
particular a particular feature of the
coordinated care organizations in the
kind of broader spectrum of healthcare
reform is ways in which coordinated care
organizations can provide alternative or
different payment mechanisms and what
sort of payment reform looks like so
we're going to be talking about some
from the nitty gritties of that in
financing of the healthcare system in
general today so before I kind of get
into that scene kind of just broad
contacts of first health care spending
in the United States so in 2013 the
United States spent two point nine
trillion dollars on healthcare that
number is only bigger for 2014 its
projected to continue to grow that's
roughly 17 points
a percent of first domestic product
which is kind of a sum total of all
things that are bought and sold in an
economy in the given year so truly a
tremendous amount kind of what makes up
the US economy this graphic shows you
from the Congressional Budget Office
what some of the spending looks like for
the for the government and the revenues
that we get in through taxes and for
those of you who are with us to see the
interns I think mostly John's
presentation um this is that same
graphic from there you can see in 2008
government spending goes up as part of
the stimulus bill when the bail out
there and you can see the CBO
Congressional Budget Office projections
going out into the future that gap
between the amount the government is
spending in the amount we take in in
revenues is kind of only increasing over
time so nationally health care spending
is a really big deal we should probably
try and think of ways to deal with this
issue looking a little bit more locally
at health care spending in Oregon to
organs spent about eight billion dollars
in 2013 on health care which is
approximately twenty percent of the
budget to give you some idea of other
things organ is spending on twenty-six
percent of the budget goes towards
education so this is something that you
can see I is also projected to grow is
kind of a of concern here in Oregon and
other states as well as very much you
see the sort of trend of increased
health care costs and spending going
into it and not having clear ways to
kind of drive down those costs that's
the the state spending on health care
the state of Oregon not the population
aboard yes correct yeah this is the
state itself yeah you're absolutely
correct so again similar sort of graphic
you can see of our expenditures
increasing above our revenues that band
increasing over time for Oregon and so
there's kind of this this broad and
perhaps intuitive and immediate question
which is what do we do about the rising
health care costs in the US how do we
manage this a better at the federal
level we see
huge reforms like the Affordable Care
Act as well as the Patient Protection
Act that have kind of dominated a lot of
news even recently this summer but
certainly at different points in time
but I think kind of a lesser-known side
of health care that you began you begin
to be a little bit more aware of when
you find yourselves embedded in health
systems or doing health systems research
is that the Center for Medicare and
Medicaid also regularly and has in the
past and is currently approved of a
number of state demonstration so these
are essentially agreement where CMS says
alright we are going to allow you to do
some sort of new experiment new
innovation or new idea for handling
handling the health care system for your
Medicaid or Medicare populations and
part of what you get in order to do this
kind of new unconventional thing is you
have to promise us that you're able to
expand coverage to people and while
maintaining quality and so currently
there are a number of state
demonstrations for accountable care
organizations so accountable care
organizations we're putting this kind of
in the terms of economic theory are a
supply-side policy lever so that is to
say these are care organizations that we
make that presumably have certain goals
metrics and defined ways in which they
interact with their patient populations
in sort of like managed care
organizations but with kind of more
oversight from communities governments
regulators and I the reason I bring this
up as a supply-side policy levers this
is a little bit different than demand
side reforms on where we would be doing
things like experimenting with
co-payments for individuals in the
Medicaid population so these are
typically low income individuals or
vulnerable communities in the first
place on the kind of historic reasoning
behind Medicaid is that these
individuals wouldn't hate co-payments
because they're sort of not able to in
first place where that might strain
their access to care in some way however
you know there are some states that are
saying maybe we introduce types of coke
payment structures for those individuals
to see if that can affect our health
care costs this is something much
different in going straight to health
providers and saying you need to begin
thinking about integrating your care
systems and coordinating in new ways
that you may be having for before and
that there are costs to be saved by
doing that so that's sort of what
affordable care organizations are doing
at the large and even drilling down a
little bit more specifically into what's
really in general behind the sort of
supply-side reform and it's a
transformation of both the delivery
system of health care as well as the
payment system which we're going to be
focusing on the second of those latter
but this is things like not only are we
talking about different ways in which we
ensure that patients have access to
their health care providers but what are
the ways that health care providers
coordinate amongst themselves amongst
insurance companies so on and so forth
to actually determine how you are paid
for the medical services that you render
and so currently the sort of predominant
model that you see in many places in the
United States is this sort of
fee-for-service model and that's to say
that there is some unit of health care
service or there's a particular thing
that you need and then someone is billed
or reimbursed for that I go into the
doctor and I say I have chest pains the
doctor says alright we're going to run
these three diagnostic tests the tests
at the end of the day insurance provider
my employer-sponsored insurance is going
to reimburse that individual or the
services they rendered um but as you can
maybe begin to extrapolate from this um
there's no clear incentive and that's
sort of that sort of world or
environment to try and keep people
healthy in the long term sort of in
layman's terms if you're getting paid
every time you do a medical service
presumably your goal would be to do as
many medical services as possible so you
can get paid the most that said it's
also worth mentioning that when we talk
about how health care providers interact
with insurance companies it's really
relatively easy to configure payment
systems it's to say it's it's easy to
track and count exactly what happened
because you just have a bill that says
you came in these four things were done
and we need to pay someone for those
four things which I it will be a little
bit important later on so this this
graphic sort of describes different ways
in which we could think about
conceivably spending on healthcare so
currently we find ourselves in this
green box where you have some unit of
service your reimbursed for that unit of
service but because there isn't much
incentive in that payment structure to
make sure that individuals are healthy
in the long term or that we're providing
the most efficient or value-based or
outcome based care we want to try and
think of other realms or types of
payments that we could move towards and
so the goal is that we try and move to
these fruits of global payments and
that's something that Oregon has been
trying to move towards and our health
care reform and so coordinated care
organizations on the CCOs which you know
you might have heard about or heard a
lot about heard none about some amount
our kind of organs brand of a countable
care organization so all of them are
community-based and kind of decided and
created based on communities and regions
they have governing boards that bring
together all sorts of different
stakeholders they are accountable to the
state of Oregon as well
the Centers for Medicare Medicaid to
perform on a number of measures of
health outcomes that have been
identified as outcomes that are
important to make sure we're they are
maintaining a sort of quality of care
whether it be the same quality of care
as before or improvements in those areas
and their goal really is these last two
things to integrate the delivery system
by integrating our physical behavioral
and oral health and also to be in paying
health care providers through a global
budget or making sort of global payments
which is that at the end of that box on
that last slide and so this sort of this
scale of this I want to give a little
bit of weight to it so the federal
government's invested almost two billion
dollars over the course of the next five
years in the state of Oregon has said
we're going to be able to return your
investment by that because of all the
savings that we are going to be able to
generate from our health care system and
that well and then we also further
agreed that we're going to lower the
medical trend by 2 percentage points so
this is something that when you talk
about state waivers and new
demonstrations this the scale and
magnitude of what's going on in oregon
health care reform really is a
revolutionary i would perhaps not go
quite so far as to say historic but it's
to say that these innovations are
definitely new compared to what we've
seen four types of ways that states have
tried to reform their health care
systems so kind of focusing on that
second real target of the CCOs which is
the global budget and coordinated care
organization so coordinated care
organizations are giving capitation
payments from this kind of global budget
that the states have on a per member per
month basis and what that means is the
state has this large pool of money for
Medicare Medicaid some of it is the
state's money and then it is matched by
the federal government and we say all
right ordinated care organization X we
are going to give you X amount of
dollars based on your underlying patient
population and so and then the state's
pay coordinated care organizations who
pay out their healthcare providers from
there the idea for this is
this shifts the the risk the financial
risk onto coordinated your
organization's you know health care
providers if they go over in terms of
the amount of costs they're being paid
they are the ones that have to assume
that now or if they come up with losses
it is because they are the ones who did
not manage care a particular way so this
isn't an attempt to try and get away
from that fee-for-service world where
there is no incentive to keep patients
healthy in the long run but a thing you
might ask yourself is what is it what is
a fair price for some bundle of patients
or some patient population I'm
accounting for the potential health care
risks and needs that they all might have
to me that sounds very complicated and
that's why actuaries are the ones at the
Oregon Health Authority who try and come
up with what that payment rate looks
like based on things like underlying
population characteristics treatment
costs operating costs health risks risks
from uncertainty in terms of the
modeling and projections they themselves
come up with and kind of a number of
other things so so is the kind of the
agent that we that we're interested in
now is how is it actuaries do this and
what's a fair price for an average
patient in some population and so so
then this issue of how exactly do we
have an actuarial rate-setting
methodology and one that is fair I'm
kind of first and moreover what is the
issue of actuarial soundness I promise
we were getting close to the punch line
and so a lot of that kind of first
question was introduced through the
balanced budget act of linking at 97
which said that the capitation rates
these kind of bundled payments for for
managed care organizations have to
ensure that patients have some
sufficient access to your care you can't
say that a patient that is high risk is
going to cost some tremendous amount and
therefore can be excluded from your pool
and that is precisely one of the reasons
why the balanced budget act was
implemented to try and deal with this
issue of managed care organizations
setting seemingly arbitrary rates or
setting rates that seemed unfair to
provide health access to the patients in
their populations and so the precise
language of actuarial soundness of the
balanced budget act says that capitation
rates must be developed in accordance
with generally accepted actuarial
principles and practices appropriate for
the populations to be covered in those
services furnished and certified as
meeting applicable regulatory
requirements by qualified actuaries I
don't know about you but when I read
that it doesn't really mean much to me
and it doesn't really seem to be saying
much of anything and in fact that was
sort of also the feeling of CMS when the
balanced budget act came out so they
requested to the American Academy of
actuaries that there has to be some sort
of rule that we actually go about saying
this because the new federal law just
said actuaries are going to come up with
rules and best guidelines to conform to
regulations to which the American
Academy of actuary said that some
general kind of ideas for how managed
care organizations set their capitation
rates should be based on historic cost
and utilization data in order to get a
good projection you should have a pretty
good idea what's been happening in the
past and that you should somehow use
that information to ensure that
subsequent rates are going to be able to
provide sufficient access of care to
your patient populations like the
balanced budget act wants you to
initially though these guidelines are
non-binding and the American Academy of
actuaries was was clear to emphasize
multiple points in their practice note
that there may be some alternative
methods or different rate setting
methodologies that could be appropriate
for this aim and that individuals should
feel should feel inclined to try and use
those if they think they're going to be
more efficient for their patient
populations and so what organ was doing
I'm starting in 2011 and having
coordinated care organizations use was a
thing called the cost template and it's
one of these examples of a sort of
alternate method where we would use
capitation rates based on this and this
sort of cost template out CCOs to report
administrative costs financial costs
generally on the costs and encounters of
different things happening in their
patient population the organ health
authorities actuaries would look at it
kind of squint and say it seems to be
valid or you were more or less on track
more importantly though is in 2011
there's a cap spent on set in aggregate
for coordinated care organizations for
how much they could be increasing their
health costs by and that was set at
three-point-four percent magically so
that Oregon could hit the target that we
said we were going to hit with the
federal government so that we didn't owe
them a lot of money at the end of her
five-year demonstration to them so then
in 2015 and even prior to that CMS had
had some problems in other states with
actuarial standards just not being
followed through the Government
Accountability Office I'm in the
Department of Justice even we're getting
ready to say CMS you have this actuarial
soundness rule but you're not really
consistent and how you ply it across
states and you need to have a more
granular examination of what states are
actually doing for their capitation
rates so taking cue from this CMS said
to the state of Oregon that in 2014 that
the cost template is not in compliance
with this and in response they also
created managed care capitation rate
setting guidelines that were now binding
so before their practice note said we
would think that you should be
considering these sorts of things in
coming up with a capitation rate now
that has shifted to say you must be
doing these sorts of these sorts of
things in order to be setting
actuarially sound capitation rates
that are in compliance with federal law
so like I said CMS was a little bit
displeased with the idea of the cost
template and told the organ health
authority about that saying that they
had concerns over the endemic
shortcomings in Oregon's rate-setting
methodology from 2011 to 2014 so this is
quite a big criticism to be levying
against the state of Oregon there was
some smaller problems that they brought
up in that letter mostly related to some
unfounded expectations about the
expansion population in general the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid said
you just seem to have overestimated a
number of things and we can't really
find the assumptions you've made for
2014 and these numbers just look a
little high to us for capitation rates
is more or less the substance of these
smaller problems but the large problems
and the ones that are in fact I'm kind
of still in question and in dialogue in
the state of Oregon are about the lack
of encounter data that this state has
submitted and the lack of granularity in
that encounter data as well as of
various unclear assumptions about how
Oregon was actually setting these rates
what methodologies they were using and
how they were calculating capitation
rates for coordinated care organizations
so Oregon Health Authority readily
amended some of these smaller issues and
in order to begin to deal with these
endemic shortcomings that the federal
government through CMS found with how
coordinated care organizations were
setting their capitation rates they said
okay for 2015 we're just going to throw
out the cost template it's been deemed
actuarially sound we're not going to
argue for it so we're just going to
throw that out and try a new methodology
for 2015 that's more rigorous the Oregon
Health Authority went so far as to hire
optimist which is an actuarial firm to
verify all CCO data in coordination with
the Oregon Health Authority and the
optimist also created an entirely kind
of new portal and methodology for the
data ferret vacation from coordinated or
care organizations
and then applied this from the 2013 data
moving forward from encounters that
occurred in order to calculate the 2015
rate so in a lot of ways uh it kind of
you know getting some of the policy
language out of this this is really to
say 4 2015 the Oregon Health Authority
throughout the PlayBook that they've
been using for how CCOs were reporting
their costs and getting paid from the
state and decided they really have to
kind of start start from square one in a
way that is in accordance with the CMS
regulations if they're going to continue
to kind of move forward with healthcare
reform and with payment reform so so now
like I said that sort of financial
report in that data verification
procedure happens because CCOs have to
in 2015 submit their data both quarterly
and monthly across things like cost
utilization administration and these
other specific financial costs like how
much cost they've incurred a crude as
well as sub capitation rates and sent of
payments alternative payments all of
that kind of more jargon but the real
idea here I think is this new data
verification process that optimists and
the Oregon Health Authority came up with
together now basically requires every
month in every quarter coordinated care
organizations to be reporting a lot of
data to them about basically their
entire financial profile in order to
solve this problem of having an endemic
shortcomings in the sort of data we
submit to the federal government and so
so this is kind of now the area in the
realm we find ourselves in but there's a
number of health policy questions that i
think are remaining not just for 2016
but also for organs kind of attempt at
health care reform moving forward the i
think kind of the most obvious question
is if the reason that we wanted to be
using global payments and we wanted to
be and one of the reasons we created
these coordinated care organizations was
to get away
from the fee-for-service world are we
still able to do that in a system that
the federal government mandates we have
to do with this degree of intensity in
the financial reporting is there still
room for coordinated care organizations
to be engaging in to sort of flexible
spending or or spending based on value
or outcomes that we originally set them
that they originally set out to do and
so so I think the this to me is still
lingering and it's something that we're
only going to kind of be able to see
moving forward some potential solutions
could be that on the CMS could offer
some sort of amendment to oregon's
waiver doesn't seem unlikely and seems
that more likely than not that would
break some federal reporting standards
and kind of violate the law the
actuarial soundness standards so it's
probably there's probably not some
political compromise between the two
bodies that we could see another
solution is that we come up with some
sort of new rate setting methodology
that solves this problem or allows for
more flexible tend spending and
coordinated care organizations but a big
problem is that actuarial world's kind
of moves slowly it would seem difficult
to come up with an entirely new rate
setting methodology within the course of
a year and sort of where I personally
feel the issue kind of ends and what I'm
curious to see what it moving forward is
I think that this kind of financial
submission puts us in in alignment with
federal rules and regulations and that
there's just going to have to be some
sort of awkward transition from a
fee-for-service world into using this
extensively reported financial data for
calculating setting and reporting
capitation rates and that there's just
going to have to be some kind of growing
pains that ccos go through sort of the
negative spin on it the positive spin
though is when we talk about maybe
scaling up accountable care
organizations for not just organ but
other places we may be learned that
there's a sort of workflow to implement
them well in terms of the first making
relationships and information channels
transitioning that into how we improve
our delivery system and coordinate
care and better ensure quality and then
from there once we scale our successful
strategies it might only be at that
point that we just have that
administrative time money and energy to
begin approaching things like developing
a very robust financial reporting system
for coordinated care organizations and
other care organizations to report on
things so that they can come up with
capitation rates and get us out of the
paper service world so yeah that is some
of what I've been working on I have to
hold it up yeah is it that they think
that the budget is just wrong like it's
too high to low do you think that one
ccos has too much giving their
population versus loved one I mean in
some ways but that i think would imply
is looking at 2016 it would be
interesting to see how we're spending
changes as we adopt the new so I was
gonna vary but you what your thoughts
are yeah so it's all of it right CMS is
concerned is that when you look at the
CCO data and then the data that OHI on
the CCOs is submitting to CMS you find
discrepancies there in terms of rates or
in terms of how you would calculate
rates so part of it is that um I think
the concern is not just are we
overpaying ccos but it's how are we
deciding how we pay ccos and is it
consistent and isn't transparent and CMS
seems to be saying it's not consistent
or transparent and it's too much
uncertainty for us to comfortably say
but this is an okay practice that you
have going on
alright our final speaker is works with
me Dave door so as he puts on his
microphone steve is also just finished
as soon you're going to go into senior
year at University of Connecticut and
he's actually very interested in going
on and to graduate school in
epidemiology so has actually spent some
of his time sort of going around and
talking to different schools about
future programs so obviously I'm very
fond of his topic here this is my
research area thank you dr. door for
that introduction my name is Steve rocky
Olli and for my presentation I will be
talking to you about risk stratification
for patients with multiple chronic
conditions so unfortunately the slides
kind of useless dr. dork I've explained
that already no it's fine don't worry
about it don't worry about it so a brief
overview of my presentation I will start
with explaining why risk stratification
is important I will then go into a brief
introduction the project that I worked
on the summer which is multiple chronic
conditions or MCC for short I will then
talking about my specific contribution
to this project as well as results
important findings and inclusions that
was able to draw last I will touch on
some of the next steps for the project
first and foremost wise risk
stratification important risk
stratification is defined as the process
of taking patients and distributing them
into different categories based on their
perceived risk for future negative
outcomes so as you can see in this
diagram here we have a group of patients
and it's the job of risk stratification
to distribute them into different groups
based on the risks so in this picture we
use different colors to demonstrate that
risk with red obviously being patient
who's high risk while grimsby more of
low risk the issue in today's society is
that doctors are very good at looking at
a patient who's showing certain symptoms
at diagnosing them with a specific
disease and then provide another problem
occasion for treatment however many
doctors fail at looking at a patient and
saying I believe that in the next year
that this patient will have a serious
negative outcome or I believe that this
patient will be relatively healthy so
through the process of risk
stratification we would be able to
properly identify these people it's
especially difficult for doctors to
identify patients with multiple chronic
conditions as these patients are usually
seeing many different doctors and
there's usually a lack of communication
between these doctors so there are
usually issues in terms of the
treatments that they are receiving and
their overall treatments so one
important fact I want to point out you
is that on average out of all the
patients who seek medical care 5% of
them will account for nearly half of all
medical medical expenditures so the risk
stratification we could potentially
solve this problem because if we can
identify which patients will be costing
healthcare system the most money we can
target them through care management
practices in order to try to mitigate
these risks examples of care management
practices would be having a care manager
be assigned to a patient and giving them
a specific treatment where they'd be
following their medications and making
sure there's strong communication
between the different doctors that
they're seeing in theory if we could
risk stratify them and apply proper care
management we would be able to reduce
the cost through help through the health
care system for an introduction to my my
project which with multiple chronic
conditions rmcc first it's important to
point out that risk stratification is
not a new phenomenon and that's actually
been around for a while however MCC is
unique in the sense that it attempts to
use EHR data for risk stratification
many previous studies have looked at the
use of sorry many eh many previous
studies have looked at use of claims
data in terms of using risk
stratification and the process for that
would be taking patients records for the
past year adding up all their costs and
then determining which patients have
cost them the most money and then they
would the insurers would target these
patients and try to reduce their future
costs however there's a lag time of
about
18 months for this to occur and that's a
large time gap where if we could use EHR
data which is constantly evolving and
it's always present we could restrepo
our patients a lot faster and then
possibly even treat them during that
18-month period and possibly prevent
some of the outcomes that could have
occurred so the objective of the MCC
project was to understand if we could
use EHR data to improve the risk score
prediction of patients right here we
have a picture of an epic a screenshot
from the epic HR which is where we
pulled most of our data from and three
sources that we used for the risk score
predictions where the problem list
encounter medical history and then a
combination of all three of those
sources for problem lists and medical
history they're very similar in the
sense that it's a place where any doctor
can write down issues that the patient
was having however problem list is
supposed to be more pertinent to what's
actually going on with the patient right
now well medical history as an a would
imply is supposed to be history so
issues that are not currently affecting
the patient but they were in the past
however many doctors do not follow these
standards and it ends up that both the
problem list and medical history will
have information on patients conditions
whether they are currently affecting
them or if they're in the past encounter
on the other hand is an EHR source that
is supposed to be more relevant in terms
of predicting patient outcomes the
encounter source is linked to a specific
instance where a patient visits a
clinician and they are treated for
specific condition so in the encounter
source you would have a documentation of
what a patient visited a clinic for
example for a complication with diabetes
and there would be a documentation
saying that this patient was treated for
their diabetes and that would be a more
relevant example as to an issue that the
patient might be having later on for a
brief overview of the experimental
design for MCC we started by reaching
out to primary care clinics throughout
Oregon and those practices that were
willing to work with us for the study we
extracted EHR data for patient-level
data on their medical history as well as
current conditions that they were that
they had the three risk or algorithms
that we use to
the risk scores are listed here we have
the modified Charleston comorbidity
index which pulls icd-9 codes out of the
EHR we have the hierarchical condition
categories or HCC which was developed by
Medicare Medicaid and then the
Affordable Care Act qualified conditions
which is unique in the sense that it
also incorporates mental health
conditions and it was enrolled by the
Affordable Care Act a few years ago it's
important to note that the risk score
algorithms are pulling data from the
baseline year of patients as well as
previous medical history and that the
risk scores that they are providing our
fourth are predicted here which is a
one-year period after the baseline
period the outcomes that we were looking
at for this experiment were hospital
visits ED visits cost and length of stay
however from my particular project I did
not look at length of stay just the
other three so for my particular project
within MCC it was my task to create a
data visualization to try to figure out
if the risk score predictions were
actually predicting what they were
supposed to because at the time that I
had gone to this project we had yet to
run any multivariate analyses to
actually determine the Civil Signet
statistical significance of the results
so I created an intermediary where we'd
be able to quickly analyze the risk
scores and try to see if they are
predicting what they were supposed to so
this diagram that I threw together here
accurately portrays my journey to the
end product I had a very large data set
that had information on patrons baseline
and prediction year risk scores for 4112
patients and i started with using a
pivot table which i have here and this
was a feature in excel that i had never
used before however it was very
intuitive and ended up saving me a lot
of time in terms of graphing the data
and getting the things that I wanted to
show this middle picture is a very good
representation of some of the struggles
and frustrations I had along the way
Excel was very difficult in terms of
formatting the data and modifying it in
the ways that I wanted to so there's a
lot of trial and error for that but I
ended up coming up with
these grafts here this is one of 36 that
ended up making and I'm fairly content
with how they turned out and I feel like
they're a very good way to represent the
data so how you would interpret this
data or the graph on the x-axis you have
the different risk scores that the
patients were given through the
algorithms on the primary x axis you
have the different or you have patient
count so the number of patients who were
given each risk score and then on the
secondary y axis you have the rate that
the outcomes and in this case you have
the rate of ED visits so if you wanted
to interpret this graph you would look
and see if you look at the pivot table
if you were given the risk score of 0
you have less than 8.5 rate of average
ed visits however if you were given a
risk score greater than 5 your rate of
ED visits jumps to over 2 so you would
say that from having a risk score of
zero to a risk or greater than 5 that
there is a four-fold increase in the
rate of ED visits one important thing to
point out would be that a majority of
the patients will fall in the low risk
score range so that's why you have very
high bars for the lower scores and
there's a very small amount of patients
in the upper bins and this goes hand in
hand with what I mentioned earlier with
about five percent of the patients
accounting for most of the outcomes also
real briefly um the general hypothesis
that we had for these graphs would be
that as the risk scores would as the
risk scores increased so with the
average rate of the outcomes this is an
example of one of the tables that I
created which this is one of three and
there will be going into the outcomes
paper that will be getting published
later on and this particular table is
looking at hospitalization outcomes so
it's organized in the sense that you can
look through the columns and it's
organized by the different EHR sources
that we pulled the data from and then
the rows represent the different risk or
algorithms that were used to generate
the risk scores one neat thing about
these tables is that all the axes are
standardized so it makes it very easy to
look down the columns or across the rows
to see general trends amongst the
different scores as you can see here
there are error bars for each of the
different points along the
line graph and these represent the
ninety-five percent confidence that our
vote for the standard error of the mean
also one issue that I was having in
terms of creating these graphs as I
mentioned before a majority of the
patients will be in the upper risk score
ranges so when you got into the higher
risk scores there are the examples where
a certain risk or would only yield three
patients with that risk score and if
there were any outliers in that sample
set of three it would drastically affect
the general trend of the line so I chose
them for the number of 30 as the
smallest sample size that any risk or
could have so with a larger sample size
it was a better generalization of the
front line for important findings and
conclusions I'm not going to take the
time to go through all 36 at the graphs
that I made so I highlighted a few
friends i wanted to point out these
three graphs here are from the problem
list EHR source and they are looking at
the rate of hospital visits this is an
example of some good results as you can
see there's a steady upward trend so as
the risk scores are increasing so do the
rates of hospital visits also it's
important to point out that if you look
at the upper risk score ranges the error
bars are relatively small so there's
minor variability and those results
which will end up not be in the case
later on it ended up turning out that
the problem list eh our source perform
the best in terms of the different EHR
sources for the prediction of hospital
visits I believe that this is the case
because as I mentioned earlier problem
list should contain specifically
problems that are currently affecting
the patient but however they could also
have instances of conditions that might
not be affecting the patient at that
time so that would be pretty indicative
of patients of multiple chronic
conditions as they could have an issue
later on that could spur a hospital
visit next these are four graphs from
the modified Charleston comorbidity
index and these are predicting ED visits
so this is an example of some poor
results as there's a flat trend line
across the board so as the risk scores
are increasing the rate of the ED visits
is remaining relatively constant and
this goes against our hypothesis because
we predicted that the rate should
increase over the increase of risk or
and the reasoning behind this is
actually because when the charlson
comorbidity score was modified it was
related to predict hospitals as opposed
to ed visits so if you go back and look
at this table here which shows all the
different outcomes for hospital visits
the top the top row is for all of the
different EHR sources for the modified
Charleston score and you can see that
actually performed relatively well for
possible business which is supposed to
do lastly I've chosen two graphs from
the hierarchical conditions categories
each risk or algorithm and they're
predicting cost so at quick glance you
can see that these graphs are or that
these outcomes are the risk score is
increasing so does the cost and on
average there's about a four-fold
increase in the rate of cost as you go
from risk or zero to the error bars are
very hot very large there's high
variability amongst the the results so
it makes it difficult to draw any
accurate conclusions however the HTC
school risk score did actually perform
the best in terms of predicting cost and
I believe that this is the case because
it was actually developed by Medicare
Medicaid strictly to predict average
cost for future patients so it makes
sense that it performed the best in the
sense now I'd like to talk about some of
the next steps for the project as I
already mentioned sorry did for that
Victor as I already mentioned we have
yet to run any statistical analyses to
determine actually which risk scores are
performing the best or which EHR sources
our best to pull from so the next step
would be to analyze and interpret these
results to figure out which is the best
and actually dr. doris team was awarded
a grant recently which i have listed
here at the bottom improving
implementation of risk prediction in
primary care and the goal of this grant
is to incorporate the findings that
we've learned from MCC and then
implement them with in primary care
clinics throughout
to try to improve their risk
stratification methods another aspect
that we would like to incorporate would
be to add a clinical intuition to the
risk scores so by adding a human
perspective of a doctor as well as the
computer-based risk or algorithm it
would create a more representative risk
score and with that I would like to once
again thank dr. David or for giving me
this opportunity to come all the way
from Connecticut to Portland it's been a
great opportunity for me and I've
learned a lot of valuable skills that
I'll be able to use later on in my
academic career I would like to thank
the CMP team Bobby Oh Tracy Raja Jesse
Shelby Lindsay and Doug for your support
throughout the summer and provided me
with plenty of tasks to keep me busy as
well as the rest of the MTC team for
assisting me with any questions I had
throughout my project I'd like to give a
special thing my cubicle buddy we spent
a lot of long office hours together and
he definitely kept me staying throughout
that time and I'd also like to thank the
rest of my fellow dms interns and with
that I would like to open it up to
comments and questions thank you yeah
in your display of the nine or so
figures hmm what's going on when the
curve starts to go down at the end so I
touched on this before so when you had
the higher risk scores you have a small
amount of patience so if one patient had
a risk or outcome that was that through
the data it didn't provide the best
results it would easily skew the trend
because there's such a small sample size
so I try to combat this is better
results than but I had originally so
what I tried to do was combine some of
the risk scores so you can't see it here
but if you look at some of the other
ones you can see that like it says the
risk or is greater than 2.5 so there are
other risks chords that we had but I
just combine those together to have a
larger sample size and then that I did a
better job at try the balance on the
trends but there are still in this is
where it would dip down at the end
there's another part of that which is
that there's no indication that these
risk scores are linear and there's an
implied linearity by sort of graphing
them out in this way their
characteristics are really weird
musically and so we see a lot of like
this thank you so he started to saying
essentially we're gonna try to predict
the five percent but that problem is the
five percent cost us 50 percent i read
your grass as doing a good job
predicting who is in the low versus of
video and every she's kind of getting
trying to get your thought on this is
that a value as well is it something we
might wanna because right even in the
good cases standard errors a huge right
and I mean you mean happens to be up so
you find upwards trend right but you're
ninety-five percent confidence about
often is it short you could go down
there's there's really no way lots of
ways we could go right so kind of it
seems more robust in this little low and
middle category yeah so obviously with a
larger sample size it was a lot
easier to get more confidence in terms
of the lower risk scores and that was
one of the challenges with creating
these upper risk score ranges because
that's what we're trying to predict and
dr. Dore can touch on this a little bit
better but the current risk score
prediction algorithms that are out on
the market today aren't actually that
great at predicting so even though we
have a lot of errors here the user these
preliminary results are actually fairly
good in terms of giving us a general
sense of what this upper five percent
actually risk or versus medium as a
cut-off so the next step people will do
which is implied by these graphs is cut
off at five percent and say I've got a
reason like a care manager that can only
address fibers in the paper which five
percent sure to have them work on other
groups like transitions of care people
who say oh for all the hospitalized
patients actually want to know the
bottom third that will never have a
readmission and so that good performance
here they would just look because they
say oh my gosh yeah I could really tell
there's this inflection as they go from
very low scores up and that'll be great
because then I can sort of look at that
two-thirds boring death using more risk
analysis on them because they're
physically in we're within the clinic's
Dale whereas in primary care you really
don't have that or in the hospital still
primary care they're gone so you just
use the information you have so that's
really probably the difference in why we
have any other questions yes
the EHR source medical history HR source
so I don't have any particular
information in terms of the actual EHR
swords and what we pulled I just had the
risk scores however the medical history
eh our source pulled from years back I
think we had about five or six years of
data from back and we pulled all of the
conditions that were listed in the
medical history list from that time
period so it's a fairly good
representation of the history of the
patients but I'm not exactly positive
with that and that one of the next steps
is dad temporality actually to it but
these were scores don't allow develop
for it so Aaron Cohen and Matt that is
nothing what sunderland are actually
sort of recalculating these adding with
two hypotheses one is very recent
history might be really more valuable
and one is very old history might be
more valuable depending on the
conditions so they're really decomposing
it and doing some machine learning
techniques to see if they can predict
you know add features and predict better
just wasn't able to do with this
you